- [Instructor] We are told
that a sample of a compound
containing only carbon and hydrogen atoms
is completely combusted,
producing 5.65 grams of carbon dioxide
and 3.47 grams of H2O or water.
What is the empirical
formula of the compound?
So pause this video
and see if you can work through that.
All right, now let's just try
to make sure we understand
what's going on.
They say that I have
some mystery compound.
It only contains carbon and hydrogen,
so it's going to have
some number of carbon,
I'll call that x.
Some number of hydrogens,
I'll call that y.
We're going to put it in the
presence of molecular oxygen
and it's going to combust
and after it's combusted,
I'm going to end up with some
carbon dioxide and some water.
And what I just drew here,
this is a chemical reaction
that I'm describing.
I haven't balanced it.
I could try to, even with the x's and y's,
but that's not the point of this video.
The point of this video is
they tell us how many grams
of the carbon dioxide we have
and how many grams of the water we have,
they tells us that right over there.
And so what we need to
do is say, all right,
from that, we can figure
out how many moles
of carbon dioxide we have,
how many moles of water we have,
and from that, we can
figure out how many moles
of carbon did we start with
and how many moles of
hydrogen did we start with?
And if we look at those ratios,
then we can come up with
the empirical formula
of the compound.
So just to start, because
I'm going to be thinking
about molar moles and molar masses
and the mass of a mole
of a molecule or an atom,
let's just get the average atomic mass
for carbon, hydrogen, and
oxygen for us to work with.
So I'll get out our handy periodic table.
We can see hydrogen has an
average atomic mass of 1.008.
Let me write that down.
So we have hydrogen is at 1.008,
and then we have carbon,
and carbon is at 12.01.
So carbon is at 12.01,
and we could also think about them
in terms of molar masses.
We could say this is gram per mole,
grams per mole,
and then last, but not
least, we have oxygen
and then oxygen is at
16.00 grams per mole.
It's the average atomic mass,
but whether we can think
of that as molar mass,
that number is molar mass.
So oxygen
is at 16.00 grams per mole.
And so now we can try to figure out
how many moles of C in
the product do we have?
So we can see that all of
the carbon in the product
is in the carbon dioxide
that's in the product,
and so we have 5.65 grams of CO2.
We can think about how
many moles of CO2 that is,
so times one mole
of CO2 for every how many grams of CO2.
Well, we just have to think about,
actually, let me just
put it right over here.
CO2,
you're going to have, let's see,
you have one carbon
and two oxygens.
So it is going to be
12.01 plus two times 16.
Two times 16.00 grams per mole,
and so let's see.
This would get us to, this is 32
plus 12.01, so that is 44.01.
And that's grams per mole,
but now we're thinking
about moles per gram,
so it's going to be one over 44.01
and so if we did just this,
the grams of CO2 would
cancel the grams of CO2
and this would give us moles of CO2,
but I care about moles
of carbon in the product.
So how many moles of carbon are there
for every mole of CO2?
Well we know that we
have one mole of carbon
for every one mole of CO2.
Every carbon dioxide molecule
has one carbon in it,
and so what is this going to get us?
So we have 5.65
divided by, divided by 44.01,
and then times one, so I don't
have to do anything there.
That is equal to, I'll round
it to three digits here,
so 0.128,
so this is 0.128
and my units here are, let's see.
The grams of carbon dioxide
cancel the grams of carbon dioxide.
The moles of carbon
dioxide cancel the moles
of carbon dioxide,
so I am exactly where I want to be.
This is how many moles
of carbon that I have.
And you can do the dimensional analysis,
but it also makes
intuitive sense, hopefully.
If this is how many grams
of carbon dioxide we have
and a mole of carbon dioxide
is going to have a mass
of 44.01 grams,
well then 5.65 over this
is going to tell us how,
what fraction of a mole
we have of carbon dioxide
and then whatever that
number of moles we have
of carbon dioxide is gonna be the same
as the moles of carbon,
'cause we have one atom of carbon
for every carbon dioxide molecule,
so that all makes sense.
And now let's do the same for hydrogen.
So let's think about moles of hydrogen
in the product,
and it's going to be the same exercise.
And if you're so inspired
and you didn't calculate
it in the beginning,
I encourage you to try to
do this part on your own.
All right, so all of the
hydrogen is in the water,
so and we know that we
have, in our product,
3.47 grams of water.
3.47 grams of H2O,
and now let's think about how
many moles of H2O that is.
So that's going to be, let's see,
every one mole of H2O
is going to have a mass
of how many grams of H2O?
And we could do that up here.
H2O, it's going to be,
we have two hydrogens,
so it's going to be two times 1.008
plus the mass, the average atomic mass
of the oxygen is going to be plus 16,
but we can also view that as
what would be the mass in grams,
if you had a mole of it?
And so this is going to
be in grams per mole,
and so this is going to be, let's see,
two times 1.008.
This part over here is 2.016,
and then you add 16 to it.
It's going to be 18.016.
18.016,
and then if I just calculated this,
this would give me how
many moles of water I have
in my product,
but I care about moles of hydrogen.
And so how many moles
of hydrogen do I have
for every mole of water?
So for how many moles of hydrogen
Well I'm going to have
two moles of hydrogen
for every mole of water
because in each water molecule,
I have two hydrogens.
And so that's going to
cancel out with that
and we're just going to be
left with moles of hydrogen.
And so this is going to be equal to,
I'll take my 3.47 grams of water,
divide it by the,
how much, how many grams a mole of water,
what its mass would be,
so divided by 18.016.
This is how many moles of water I have.
Now for every,
for every molecule of
water, I have two hydrogens,
so then I will multiply by two.
Times two is equal to zero point,
I'll just round three
digits right over here.
0.385.
0.385 moles of hydrogen.
So now we know the
number of hydrogen atoms.
We know the number of carbon atoms,
and to figure out the empirical
formula of the compound,
we can think about the
ratio between the two,
so I'm gonna find the ratio
of hydrogens to carbons.
And that is going to be equal to,
I have 0.385 moles of hydrogen
over, over
0.128 moles of carbon.
0.128 moles of carbon,
and what is this equal to?
And it looks like it's
going to be roughly three,
but let me verify that.
In my head, that seems so,
I already have the hydrogen there,
and so if I divide it by 0.128,
I get, yep, pretty close to three.
Now actually, I think if I, yep,
pretty close to three, so there you go.
This is approximately three,
and so I can, with pretty good confidence,
this was very close to three.
I could say for every carbon,
I have three hydrogens
in my original compound,
in this thing right over here.
So the empirical formula
of our original compound
for every one carbon,
I have three hydrogens.
So CH3,
and we are done.